over the years I have read over a
hundred books ranging from productivity
tips fantasy Thrillers however I wanted
to condense it down into three books
that I feel have changed my life from
the way I approach studying to how I
decided to create a YouTube channel
these are the books I come back to when
times gets off and these are the books I
tell people to read when they are
starting on their journey to becoming
more wise as a student so hi I'm shilos
Fraser a third year PhD student in
computational neuroscience and today I
really want to introduce you to three
books that have really changed the way
that I approached studying and how I
manage my study routine so let's get
straight into it so the first book I
want to talk about is the book show your
work from Austin Cleon and this is a
book in a series so this is maybe one of
the smallest books I've read and that's
on this list but I think it really made
a deep impression on me so if you have
to write a lot of essays you have big
projects or you have extensive hobbies
and you really want to show part of it
but you're kind of nervous and you don't
know which part to show I think this is
a really good book to start with because
I think nowadays in our economy a lot of
the part on of the economy is geared
towards entertainment and I wish we
would go a little bit more towards
creativity and producing new ideas and I
think this book has really changed the
way I view entertainment and change the
way I feel creativity as a whole so
there are three lessons that I learned
from the book so the first one is to
steal good ideas and this doesn't mean
you got to go around plagiarizing
everything you see of course give credit
where credit is due but one main message
of the book is that at the end of the
copy you will find yourself and I
personally really like that I think when
we are starting as students in our
creative Journey or on our Learning
Journey there's so much we still have to
incorporate and I think one of the best
and fastest ways to do this is to follow
Masters that you really like so for
example if you have a professor that you
really like their research I think it's
okay to really delicately first follow
the protocol they have written and then
afterwards think about how you can
improve the idea and also one of the big
things that he says is that you are
usually not able to create an exact copy
of the idea you're trying to copy so to
say by trying to copy an idea you can
kind of find your own style doing that
and one thing that really helped me
doing this is to create a second brain
which I also talked about in this video
but that's really to collect a lot of
ideas that you come across and try to
recombine them in such a way that it's
kind of Novel and new and creative so
the second tip that I got from the book
is to learn in front of others this has
really changed the way I approach
creativity because I used to think that
you could only show certain parts of
your work when it was in the final end
stage but actually by showing your work
in front of others there are a lot of
benefits one of them is that you get
feedback fast and early so if you're for
example a research student I would
highly recommend to here and there post
certain tweets about your research to
see what people in the field have to say
about it another big thing for me is
that I usually think another fellow
student can help a student more than the
professor so if you learn in front of
others you can show people how you learn
certain things and I think for me that's
one of the main reasons I started this
YouTube channel that's to show how I got
to where I am today and kind of show
which way I took for if people want to
go a similar route or they also want to
study Neuroscience I think really
incorporating this idea that it's okay
to learn in front of others will get you
quite far actually and furthermore we
allow people to connect with our work
and process so one of the writers I
really like Brandon Sanderson he posts
online every day how many words he's
written and he also interacts a lot with
his fans and I think by doing this we
connect with not only the writer Brandon
Sanderson but also the person Brandon
Sanderson and how he creates his work
and at least for me it really made me
admire not only his writing but also his
dedication towards his work how he gets
up every day and every day he writes for
a couple of hours and I find that really
inspiring and I think by learning in
front of others you can also Inspire
other people hopefully and the last tip
I got from the book is don't curb your
passions and this is to say that you
shouldn't cut off certain passions
because you think they're not worthwhile
in your endeavors towards a certain
career for example so I think in
University we're really stimulated to
choose one path where usually asked to
choose a certain major or minor and kind
of stick with that and try to really
deep dive into those topics but I think
sometimes early on in our journey we
don't really know which of our passions
is actually kind of gold so the second
book I want to recommend is a true
classic and it's probably the first a
self-help book that I have ever read but
it really really changed my way to how I
approached studying how I think about
learning and in which manners I learn so
it's How to Become a Straight A Student
by Cal Newport of course the title
already tells you what the book is about
it's about different studying techniques
for you to get as good grades as you can
and one of the main messages of the book
is this differentiation between pseudo
work ask Al Newberg calls it and real
work so pseudo work according to called
new report so the pseudo worker looks
and feels like someone who is working
hard he or she spends a long time in the
library and is not afraid to push late
into the night but because of a lack of
focus and concentration doesn't actually
accomplish much so probably if you look
around you if you're studying right now
you will see a lot of people that are
doing pseudo work so at least for me
when I'm studying with my friends what I
notice a lot is that most people are
actually talking or they're watching a
certain video or they're just
highlighting parts of the text but then
not actually super focused on their work
call Newport really talks about this
phenomenon a lot of us spent 12 hours
learning but we're actually just doing
pseudo work and probably all of this
learning could be condensed in a few
hours before lecture and after a lecture
so one of the main formulas that he then
created was work accomplished is time
spent times intensity of focus so one of
the things you have to focus on is not
only the time you spend studying but
also the focus you spend studying and
usually when you increase the latter one
the amount that you have to study goes
down so I really learned from the book
too instead of cram all my study work on
a Sunday night to for example after
every lecture go over the lecture
material for half an hour and try to
incorporate it and this way actually it
allowed me to have a lot of free time
and still get relatively good grades and
aside of this he also has a lot of
amazing study tips so one that for me
really changed the game and this is if
you're are doing a technical course I
really want to give this to you is to
collect the problems you get over the
semester so for example every time you
have a lecture usually professors go
over certain problem sets and they give
you the solutions and I would write all
of these down and also I would write
down the problem says sets we had to do
during homework and then at the end of
the semester before an exam I would make
these big combined problem sets for one
week I would just go over all these
problem sets and I think this really
works for technical courses because
they're usually really applied and you
don't have to wrote memorize but you
have to know how to solve certain
problem sets and by having these big
problem sets and going over them I could
kind of see where I stumbled or where my
reasoning was wrong and then I would
just go to the professor as soon as I
figured this out instead of trying to
shove all of this to the end of the
semester and trying to think of problems
that I maybe had to solve or maybe
didn't and for me this really he works
creating these big problem sets really
allowed me to see where I was good at
the technical courses and where I wasn't
that good still so the last book I want
to talk about is more for your mental
well-being and I got it recommended by a
friend last year and after I read it I
really realized how important this book
would have been for my student times so
the book is called atlas of the Heart by
brene Brown and I want to start with
this quote from atlas of the heart that
I think really describes what the book
is about if we want to find a way back
to ourselves and one another we need
language and the grounded confidence to
both tell our stories and be stewards of
the stories that we hear so in his book
brene Brown explores 87 of the emotions
and she tries to give us new language to
express and understand our emotions and
this is because emotional granularity
which is an individual's ability to
differentiate between the specificity of
their emotions has been shown to be be
correlated with how well we regulate our
emotions so if you have a higher
emotional granularity usually your
ability to regulate your emotions is
also better and by being able to put
different names to different situations
we are able to better understand these
situations and perhaps manage them and I
think the more you're able to learn the
skill during your student times this
will just really help you later in life
also if you struggle with your emotions
during your work or if you have family
issues the more we understand ourselves
the better we are able to understand
others so every chapter starts with the
same places we go when dot dot and one
chapter that I personally really liked
or that really resonated with me was the
places we go when things don't go as
planned so the emotions we feel then are
boredom disappointment expectations
regret discouragement resignation and
frustration and I personally really
liked how brene Brown explained boredom
so according to brene Brown boredom is
the desire for activity that is
satisfying without the ability it can
leave us feeling frustrated and Restless
or lethargic and I think during my
studies right now as a PhD student I
often feel this sense of tiredness and I
used to kind of classify this tiredness
as just being tired from the PHD but
looking at this definition and looking
at the situations I've been in a lot of
times I think I was actually not tired I
was just being bored of certain parts of
the work and after this prolonged for a
long time I felt really lethargic
afterwards and one thing I realized by
classifying some of these feelings as
boredom is that the solutions for this
feeling is not for example to rest which
would be the solution in the case I was
just tired but the solution is actually
to search for things that really excite
me so for example this is going to an
exercise class watching a really good
movie or being inspired in some way and
at least for me that allowed me to
manage this emotion a bit better and I
think really if you go over this book
quite carefully you will understand
yourself a little bit better and perhaps
others as well so these are the books
that I personally really enjoyed if you
are missing a book that for you really
changed the way you approach studying or
how you think as a student I would love
to know and perhaps read it as well so
put it down in the comments below and
otherwise see you next week bye